[Musik]
pippilotta viktualia rollgardina
pfefferminza efraimstochter langstrumpf
pippi lebt ohne eltern aber mit asse und
fährt in ihrer villa kunterbunt und
macht was sie will hat nie schlechte
laune und unglaubliche kräfte
erfunden hat die schwedische
schriftstellerin astrid lindgren als
geburtsstunde gilt der zehnte geburtstag
ihrer tochter
denn für sie erschuf lindgren das kleine
freche mädchen mit den roten zöpfen die
verlegerin silke weitendorf war das
erste kind in deutschland das die
geschichte lesen durfte bisher kannte
sie war wirklich diese besondere stark
mutig und dann noch anbieten also völlig
ungewöhnlich so etwas so ein mädchen
kennen zu lernen oder vor mir zu lesen
als astrid lindgren das manuskript das
erste mal einen verlag anbot schrieb sie
bitte informieren sie nicht das
jugendamt nicht nur in schweden auch in
deutschland kannte aber bald jedes kind
pippi langstrumpf kaum eine andere
nation hat sich so sehr in diese kleine
naturgewalt verliebt wie die ist auf
jeden fall das mädchen die
kinderliteratur eine kindheit ohne pipi
finde ich als mädchen ist überhaupt
nicht denkbar weil sie einem den mut
gibt ganz stark zu sein und jede
situation zu meistern und einem ganz
viel mut macht für alles was da kommt
und die kinder die finden sie einfach
toll
völlig egal wann den weg geht und sika
hat sie hat ein pferd mitten in der
stadt und sie kann das hochheben bettes
dann hat sie hier so dass wir auch
machen aber auch anlässen wir es in zwei
gesprächen in deutschland feiern viele
buchläden ihren geburtstag
so wie hier in berlin kreuzberg wir
verkaufen pippi langstrumpf sehr gut und
gerne aber ich denke es wird noch mehr
gelesen als verkaufter viele ihrer alten
hippie ausgaben aufheben und ihren
kindern wieder vorlesen so haben wir
gemacht und bestimmt ganz viele andere
familien auch starke mädchen die sind
heute genauso wichtig wie vor 75 jahren
und so wird uns pippi langstrumpf wohl
noch lange stark beeindrucken